at five in the morning at the beginning of 6
there were explosions that it was not clear where it was yet
, well, somewhere in the hours of Larna to reflect everyone,
there was information that
it was the arrival of Chinese equipment,
which is located across the road
from us and, accordingly, a blast wave
in our third or fourth  in the second
building, the windows flew out,
most likely it was in for 1 or a
blast wave, and well,
they found it, and right here under the window on
the other side
there is nothing to do
here in this booth on well, where was the hall
on the day there was a wardrobe for the
mission of improving thousands  get acquainted here
mono behind the back and c
search along the street Pushkin
dance one of the administrative ones
move
xps but you know such
nibulon of the chosen son of territorial
defense and lumpy and
press here for us and for him the beauty from and the fact
for and were on the market sixty-ninth hand
out the
old  building in